I it must be nice to have your dedicated
personal medical team in the
presidential suite of a whole Hospital
dedicated taking care of presidents
after arriving by helicopter Dr Sun lost
his grandfather to coid 19 as well as
friends and colleagues the president's
message playing down the virus felt
personal even offensive people were
literally going to cardiac arrest in the
waiting rooms I had to start my shift at
8:00 in the morning within the first 5
minutes being told about falling up on
patients overnight waiting for a scan
only to find out those patients have
been dead for 20 30 minutes already I
mean that was my day that that was the
how I started my work shift uh how was
yours but from a medical Viewpoint Dr
Sun was also concerned in what he saw of
the president's condition the way he was
breathing he looked exactly like how my
grandfather died from Co where he he
felt fine he said he was fine but after
two weeks staying in the hospital it was
just too much and then he suddenly he
suddenly died the president's discharge
from hospital delighted his supporters
Donald Trump presenting it as another of
many fights he's overcome but the tone
of his message that there was nothing to
fear felt deeply out of touch as America
passed the Grim Milestone of 210,000
lives lost for many the triumphant show
at the White House Jarred with the
reality for grieving families don't let
it dominate you don't be afraid of it
it's absolutely dominating my life Nisha
lost her father just two weeks ago he
had diabetes but was otherwise healthy
and at 67 he had big plans for his
retirement but his deterioration was
rapid yeah we absolutely feel his loss
um he's not here to play with his
grandsons he's not going to be here to
see Milestones of my own life um my kids
um
so there's a void in my family that I'm
not sure Donald Trump could ever
understand as America's Medical
Community braces for a second wave it's
long been feared the president's
understanding is infected by politics
Sally Lockwood Sky News
Maryland